In a recent conversation with Vanity Fair,
Avengers: Infinity War screenwriters Christopher
Markus and Stephen McFeely revealed that Smart
Hulk almost made his dramatic debut in the
third act of that film, during the battle
of Wakanda.
The wide-ranging interview pulled back the
curtain on the massively complicated process
through which the two writers hammered out
the plot for the Infinity War and Endgame.
Banner's transformation into Professor Hulk
was originally set to take place during Infinity
War at a time in the scripting process when
the film's final act was completely different
from the one we eventually ended up seeing.
In this early version, each of the Avengers
faced a gut check before the final battle
in Wakanda a gut check of a very Strange nature.
Markus explained:
"There was a sequence in [Infinity War] where
[the Avengers] went into the places in the
Doctor Strange universe called the Mindscape,
and everyone faces themselves.
It was great but had absolutely nothing to
do with anything."
McFeely continued to say that if this had
been kept, Hulk's entrance into the Battle
of Wakanda would have been pretty memorable:
"The Hulk refuses to come out, if you remember,
and [in the early story line] they eventually
came to a realization or a compromise, and
he busted out of the Iron Man suit, and beats
the heck out of this [monster]."
Breaking down the reason for the change, though,
McFeely pointed out that one too many victorious
moments during that fateful melee would have
diluted Avengers: Infinity War's march toward
Thanos' ultimate victory.
In doing so, he also revealed that the two
movies' weird shooting schedule meant that
a key Endgame scene had to be re-shot once
it was determined that Professor Hulk wouldn't
pop up in Infinity War.
"That whole third act is a march toward losing,
and this Hulk scene is a big win, right?
It's a guy solving his problem and being a
funny character because now he's eloquent.
We had to, at the last second, scrap all that,
put aside all these scenes that used to have
Smart Hulk, and then reshoot the first act
of Endgame... that used to have the Smart
Hulk."
Markus elaborated that another reason for
pushing Smart Hulk's debut until the first
act of Endgame helped illustrate the changes
everyone had gone through after the five year
time jump.
"We wanted everybody to have this enormous
journey in the five-year jump, and to really
see, in sometimes shocking ways, how the loss
had affected them.
We hadn’t given Banner [a change] because
we had transformed him earlier, and he had
nowhere to go.
Suddenly, by needing to take it out of the
first movie, it was the perfect thing."
"I put the brains and the brawn together,
and now look at me.
The best of both worlds."
This helps to explain a significant mystery:
why Hulk, in all his green glory, was shown
at the Battle of Wakanda in the trailers for
Infinity War.
Markus and McFeely confirmed that portions
of the climactic battle were shot in which
Banner went into battle as the Hulk, but those
scenes also had to be removed and then re-shot.
The massive Vanity Fair interview helps to
illustrate why everyone is still interested
in parsing out the finer points of how Infinity
War and Endgame were made so long after the
fact.
There are probably no two blockbusters in
existence with more moving parts, and it's
easy to see how things could have gone disastrously
wrong at virtually any stage.
Fortunately for fans of superhero cinema all
over the world, Markus, McFeely, and co-directors
Joe and Anthony Russo somehow managed to make
all of those moving parts sync up as close
to perfectly as seems possible.
It all resulted in two of the finest comic
book movies ever made, and in the case if
Endgame, the single biggest film of all time.
Still... we would have absolutely freaked
out to see Hulk literally busting the Hulkbuster
suit.
Unfortunately, when you're in the business
of making ultra-blockbusters, even some perfect
moments have to go to make the final product
work.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
MCU moments are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.